I don't get into [ __ ] for dinner this is
focused on one of the biggest body wood
foam sets the security year is really
tight as there are loads of high-profile
stars inside and that's me chased up as
a foam crew member in order to
infiltrate a movie scene to find an
a-list celebrity and make my new friend
fence and then a young girl on the beach
named saeki whose name literally
translates to blue it means friend
furthermore she asked if I'd seen the
seed on my map I went home that night
convinced to create something with her
to accept the challenge no matter what
the idea oh there she is
and if you still confused as to what
this whole seed map and seed idea is all
about that's totally cool I bought this
global map which you can find are not
normal show.com where you plant a seed
which is an unfinished idea in your city
each week I choose a new seed and prior
to that city and completed with you
this week's seed is together we should
break into Bollywood this is going to be
Maddie's welcome to my new iki show not
norfolk's of this malaria procedures OCD
deflection not
switch mister
a long long time ago when the Indian
population first took to cinema it
became a binding fabric unlike a book or
novel had satisfied the Indian public in
a way no prior medium had which was due
to the high illiteracy rate back then
combined with segmentation of different
languages in the 1970s Indian cinema
overtook America as the world's largest
foam producer and a term Bollywood was
coined which is the largest of its kind
in the world and they say to break into
it is almost impossible let's see
hey I'm ready to come and meet you where
are you right now
you gotta get an ad on TV cool
[Music]
Hey
and how much
[Music]
so what you just saw was a mixture of
bollywood style dance and Bharat Natyam
it is an Indian classical style dance
for me dance is this form of
communication where I can put myself out
there and it's this security that I get
when I'm dancing and I don't know why
but it just feels like that is the
purpose to what I'm doing amazing and
tell me about Bollywood
so Bollywood is the toughest industry to
break into and get given a chance and
for me it's a matter of confidence I
have a lot of struggle creatively with
self-doubt and if I know that if I can
do there's a Viking Michaela chance in
Bollywood I can prove it to myself that
I can do it amazing when I watched
psyche dance she was a completely
different person from the reserved
unassured yong-chol had met the day
before she was bald graceful expressive
I'm no wizard of the dance part formed
but to me she seemed insanely talented I
instantly became eager to host elevator
I tend to organize this vanity trailer
in order to think like a star one needs
to feel nice my incredibly simple but
very complicated plan to break into
Bollywood is infiltrate to foam six find
mega famous Bollywood superstar play my
idea about the seed map and Sachi and
boom break Sachi into the Bollywood
industry if none of that works I am
gonna be making a video about this and
then hopefully somebody will recognize
her amazing talent and give her her
chance anyway it's on this is not normal
show it's all about going to the ends of
the earth to try and make things a
possibility there are a few major
Bollywood productions happening in the
Mumbai city centre tomorrow
but the biggest being a Netflix show
starring Jacqueline Fernandes if you
don't know who Jacqueline Fernandez is
she is a major deal
[Music]
and after some research she seems I
shall be a perfect candidate and really
understanding if I had to come and speak
to her so I've come up with a plan in
order to be able to infiltrate that
phone set so then I organize one walkie
talkie with headgear unmov'd bag with a
GoPro hidden inside army styled hat a
pair of pants with multiple pockets one
crew shirt take away Starbucks coffee
hiking boots this isn't my first rodeo
it's time to hit in so up top here is
for me stunts studios which you can see
and Jackie Dean will be inside there is
a guard outside but I think I look
pretty convincing I'm a part of the fit
shooting inside
Netflix and yeah I work with chuckle
infant Fernandes out of course a little
this said the security guards then just
left me standing I think I'm just gonna
make a paper
[Music]
[Music]
and it yeah she's gone that way
thank you some man just told me of a
Japanese trailer is to try and get on to
the actual city
hey what are you from me oh yes please
thank you so much
[Music]
hey you know Jacqueline Fernandez yeah I
was told that I couldn't use this clip
but in short I explained my idea to her
management and they said that they would
speak to Jacqueline when she came off
set in a couple of hours so much so just
wait outside
you will come outside you promise
[Music]
exactly gonna meet you right now what
yeah I'm so like honored and impressed I
don't even know that You Know Who I am
of course we know who this guy is come
on down seriously we have looked up to
you as a content creator as a director
it was at this point I realized that
Jacqueline would definitely be keen on
making sakis dream come true here make
yourself comfortable
please change thank you so much
hey it's done see you won't believe it
okay I'm going to fetch you much I've
got jacqueline fernandez that wants to
watch she does
I'm not even like this is I can't even
tell you again
[Music]
- you nervous I can't believe I'm
actually gonna meet Jacqueline Fernandez
[Music]
very good did you see my special chair
this of what it's like to be in
Bollywood okay where you gonna dance
right yet yes amazing yes have you got a
little stage ready for her in my vanity
si
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
Wow
[Applause]
that was so brilliant thank you yes
thank you how are you you killed it she
could make it in bunny whit I've totally
with that seriously that means you have
worked really hard to be able to dance
like that there was so much I want to
cry parents right here like seriously oh
my gosh amazing and don't forget you're
awesome and I'll see you next week Hey
thank you that's funny you should ask
now I'm gonna plug my Skillshare class
that you should definitely go and watch
full making is a never-ending practice
there's always a lot to consider and
even more to learn I remember being in
school and just never been keen on
learning anything ready but as soon as I
started filmmaking I really just wanted
to find out more and continue growing my
repertoire of skills and and I find the
most reliable tutorials and the best
kinds of classes to do are on Skillshare
where they have thousands of different
classes covering tons of different
creative skills and even more it's
highly affordable it cost less than ten
dollars a month for an annual
subscription two of my favorite classes
that have really helped me along the way
to the Murtagh Rafi basics understanding
filmmaking style and low-budget
filmmaking tips and tricks for an indie
look
think I'm super excited for something
that I've done for the very first time
is I created my own Skillshare class
I've just uploaded it a lot of people
have asked in my comments how I create
my seeing sounds and how I utilize sound
and rhythm to kind of create this motion
with my edits so I made a class about it
on Skillshare because Skillshare
sponsored this video you can sign up
with the link in the description to get
a two month free trial to learn how to
make your own seeing sounds and more
therefore again just a massive thank you
to Skillshare for sponsoring this video
make sure that you click on the link in
the description to get your to man free
trial other than that
don't forget your awesome great and I
can't wait to see you next week
Wednesday I just want to say a huge
thank you to my sponsors epidemic sound
and bnh photo video don't forget to
subscribe to my channel as well as
Jackie in this channel I'll link after
next week's seed is in Taiwan